no giunge da giuda giù dalle giuda il
letto fa vj simulator la mattina verrà a
tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a questo
momento io sono fan j e siamo su get
another e xaus thing dei che in italia
significa ancora un altro giorno esausto
più o meno come sono questa persona
senza ossa e che deve deve arrivare deve
super dei veri che cosa va bene non so i
comandi c'è più o meno in realtà è un
casino muoverlo è molto più di quanto
sembri però posso strisciare sui muri
really ti fai capire che cosa tra
minchia stai facendo
ok o sotto sotto va bene sono studio
striscio perché sulle cose striscio tipo
solid snake non devo toccare i cuscini
perché se non mi addormento quello che è
successo prima sul letto però posso
scavalcare le cose insomma posso andare
e l'obiettivo è raggiungere la porta
perché stanno bussando beh la smettiamo
di bussare per cortesia che non va beh
allora uno compra dei comodini un po più
piccoli 2 e non mettersi cuscini ovunque
insomma un problema adesso cosa devo
fare tipo prince of persia sui muri
della striscia ragazzi è uguale a me vi
giuro identico quanto capisco quest'uomo
porca vacca niente devo dribblare i
cuscini ben as pratico e nota è
veramente figo come giochi il movimento
è lo stesso di andare a comandare solo
un po più appiccicoso la faccenda però
ok se ti ragazzi quando andate a scuola
la mattina adesso che inizia a scuola
non è sempre una cosa brutta che vi non
dovevo dire la proverei tra un po riecco
fate così la mattina appena vista appena
salite sul banco riacquistate le ossa
prima di salire sul banco dal vostro
letto a scuola trascinate vi sono me
viene fuori una roba carina
ci devo evitare i cuscini e belli e
realistico al massimo con quale
movimento di culo un po squadrato tra
l'altro no no no
a basta proprio toccarlo con il piedino
buongustaio tra l'altro come potete
notare in basso a destra c'è scritto tre
ial version che questa versione di prova
per questo gioco è talmente bello che
hanno deciso di svilupparlo in una
versione full che uscirà non so quando
spero ma il piano piano che qual è la
situazione sfugge di mano in un attimo
perfetto let's go che pro gamer si
ragazzi io credo che dopo questo se
riesco a fini socio probabilmente entro
nei face comunque east a porta non ci
arriveremo mai deduco allora questa
parte veramente difficile perché non
riesco a girare il tizio a meno che non
riesca a toccare il cucinare
scompaginare nazionale cansino mi sembra
di parcheggiare con la macchina ha già
non ho la macchina è iper mica che
manovra e questa era veramente un casinò
sta parte perché come i tocchi un
cuscino proprio basta sfiorarlo che ci
sale sopra che culo una nota bene sì
però sta porta non è che può c'è male
non mi abbasso vivo non sono vivo
scherzavo sono morto va bene mi sono
fatto malissimo piano piano perfetto ma
posso salire sopra mentre sale dopo ok
con quale fisica
occhio che ti schiaccia sono vivo sono
io sono vivo vai così tutto calcolato
amico mio tutto calcolato
perfetto ci arriveremo la porta non lo
sento lo so io lo so che che bussa porca
di una vacca modà un'ora e mezzo non ci
arriva neanche alla maniglia
poco meglio scherza così che si arriva
era ovvio non ho fatto non arrivarci è
pure ecco infatti tornato a dormire
avevamo to be wired è il mio compleanno
io voglio solo dormire un regalo fatemi
fitusi alla fine del gioco 2 minuto
ragazzi miei è uscita fuori che c'è una
versione più elaborata di jett a noi
perché siccome ho avuto un successo
incredibile ma lo hanno fatto pure in
coreano visto che si parla un sacco in
soggiorno party game allora andiamo su
poi sceglie il personaggio bob fisso uno
che si chiama bob non può non sceglierlo
ok avigliano migliorato la grafica di
brutto veramente c'è anche whatsapp sul
telefono ma non a che gioco fatto bene
sono alto affluente po il po il problema
è che o ecco siamo partiti
mica quanto è migliorata la grafica
avevo riuscito il gioco completo e
niente già perso nel dimenticato che i
cuscini sono bastardi statal ci si muove
col mouse
va bene e non ho capito cioè non devo
sempre toccare i cuscini quindi immagino
devo passare di qua giusto e fa quanto
fatto meglio
e bellissimo ok
devo andare a con più e ad essi sono un
programmatore giustamente va dal
computer buy dopo tre ore che sia
arrivato a carni che ci ha addirittura
la narrazione che gioco incredibile
diventa minchia d'altro po diventa batte
il film ragazze a casa amica torca
boyake testata non pensavo si potesse
ritirare le testate michele va avanti
dove devo andare vico aiuto ama sentirei
una spinta lui continua proprio a salire
per il resto dell'universo capito questo
passato da dove sto passando porca vacca
no ma è un cuscino mobile come file
addormentarti squadra lo stesso sto
gioco vi prego quindi stavolta però non
devo toccarli con la testa posso
toccarli con conduttore ma con la testa
no molto chiaro promossa di ricovero
sociali veloce la c'è veloce con la
testa mi tocca ok perfetto però poi
tirare testate ai vasi in tutto questo
porca vacca che male come ho trovato
questo gioco nella mia vita come sta
parte ragazzi è veramente un casino vi
giuro che è veramente un casinò ei no è
che nei campionati mondiali di corna
piano piano piano ho pure i vasi che si
muovono ok perfetto
ci ho messo una vita ma va bene o e la
poltrona cosa fa la luce la mia testa è
diventata ancora più pesante di prima sì
ma questo ha un obiettivo c'è qualcuno
che mi bussa alla porta o cosa è vero
adesso vivo molto più lento porca vacca
difficilissimo adesso vai vai spingi
[Musica]
certo che io mica mi sono ridotto la mia
vita a giocare veramente dei giochi
strani ma questo porca vacca se li batte
tutti
come ho fatto a svenire ok se ripreso va
bene lo svenuto dal sonno è chiaro ma
come fa ma non svenire lo so e vabbè
allora che che problemi nel mondo ma io
posso avere per giocare a sta roba
spiega a la lampada mi fa riprendere
spiegamelo forse mi sto sbagliando io
che se c'è altri check point o veloce
madonna poi mi sono salvato vai vai vai
del suo veloce veloce di sfondare tutto
arrivare lassù di sfondare tutto mai
veloce quanto tempo santa 67 ok arrivato
su arrivato sono di altro soggetto
perfetto un'ora un'ora di tempo per fast
a cagata incredibile ma scusatemi che
non ho capito ma sto tizio si addormenta
a caso o quand'è che si addormentano
perché non capisce quando tengo troppo
premuto c'è un modo in cui si addormenta
proprio os arrivata la porta tutto sto
casino sono arrivato pure alla porta
pensate che ne sto messo cioè una sorta
di getting over it molto più pigro
richieste di ciao sui lanci cuscini come
funzionano solo fare qua a minchia eh
vabbè allora è ormai impossibile aiuto
pavia va via via aia sono tutti sono
addormentato così è imbattibile o
perfetto
mike è esploso mike è esploso dai che
gioca tuo tifo che ti lancio uscire ti
addormenti ok tipo la matematica a
scuola uguale anche mi addormentavo
vicino come entrava improvvisi
chiudevano gli occhi impossibile è
difficilissimo porco schifo aia e va beh
ma non è veramente infatti chi è che ha
inventato sta roba
quindi dopo devo andare a vedere chi la
fa voglio sapere il nome sono il nome di
chi l'ha fatto per capire chi a chi
vanno gli oscar
ma perché dormi mag n stai sveglio
cristo
colpi cosa fa cosa fanno e che barbie e
bug ma è così e così si è pagato sei
pagato tutto vai vai vai se non lo sono
portato dietro
che culo cos'è sta roba a minchia vado
più veloce una soda sto male alla pl
piazze si allontanano addirittura a ciò
che non so quanto possa durare l'effetto
vai vai veloce veloce loach è perfetto
che dribbling bene non fate domande sono
tornate a letto sono riuscito a tornare
qui come è possibile
bravissimo sei un fenomeno thank you for
plain ma grazie a te di avermi regalato
questa perla
un tempo le le le opere d'arte erano
tipo il il bronzo di riace amore psiche
la cappella sistina oggi c'è questo che
non è male è per carità io riprenditi
compilando il questionario e va bene
why do you think this game is
interesting ibi cause it might be of
myself a lot ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come al solito 18 momento mi
piace anche ai social comino tutta una
descrizione sera siete tristi ti
chiedevi r ci vediamo al prossimo video
sempre che non tocchi la testa col
cuscino la testa se perché non tocchi
cuscino con la testa che il colpa di sto
gioco non so più parlare perdonata in
bei ragazzi
[Musica]